welcome to the man of recaps this is
miss marvel meet kamala khan a teenage
girl from jersey city who is a huge
super fan of everything superhero
tonight is the first ever avenger con
where she's gonna cosplay as her
favorite captain marvel and it should be
the best night of her life but to go she
needs permission from her parents and
they're not really getting it she's at
that age where they still treat her like
a kid but she's a teenager now and it's
awkward so for the first time in her
life she disobeys her parents and sneaks
out of the house with her best friend
bruno goes to avenger con it's an
awesome event it's the first time we
really get to see in universe how
popular these heroes are now just
earlier kamala found this cool bangle
that belonged to her grandmother and
she's like oh this will spice up my
costume and personalize it but what's
this so it starts glowing and once she
gets up there wow lights powers yeah
that's super cool but she accidentally
caused some damage and oh the hammer
she's gotta save this influencer
and so her dreams come true kamala is a
superhero but obviously right now a
grounded superhero her best friend bruno
is obviously a science genius and helps
her figure out her powers turns out
they're not coming from the bengal the
bengal just unlocked the powers she had
within her in the comics of course she
has body stretching powers like mr
fantastic but apparently that's hard to
see gi so instead this version of the
character creates solid light which lets
her like run around on platforms there's
a big shake up in her normal life too
when she meets the hot new guy in school
komron with their shared pakistani
heritage they hit it off much to the
dismay of bruno who seems to have a
crush on kamala her other best friend
nakia is a real go-getter still in high
school but running for the mosque board
and by the way this whole show is a
really great and fun representation of
pakistani and muslim culture that is
just not shown that much on american tv
now when a kid gets himself into trouble
it's time for kamala's first superhero
moment she suits up and light steps on
up there but being a superhero is pretty
difficult it's a moderate success but by
now this new hero nightlight has caught
the attention of the department of
damage control they find her and try to
bring her in but she's rescued by komron
he introduces her to his family that
know all about her powers because they
were friends of her great grandmother
and are ageless interdimensional beings
called jinn don't worry though komron is
actually 17 it's not a twilight
situation now the bengal is some ancient
artifact that unlocked her ability to
channel the mystical energy newer and
they need kamala's help that's the only
way they can open the gate back to their
own world but science guy bruno crunches
the numbers and opening an
interdimensional gate seems like it'll
be very dangerous so kamala stalls for a
bit because it's time for her brother's
wedding which is just an awesome event
but turns out her auntie's a little bit
evil it's like i'm tired of waiting so
comrade goes to warn kamala as the jin
are wedding crashing it's a big old
super fight kamala bram yeah a big fist
of light but when evil anti grabs the
bracelet they're interrupted by a vision
of a train and then they're interrupted
by the department of damage control who
arrest all the gin but kamala gets away
but now she gets a call from her nani in
pakistan who's like hey i saw that train
too so kamala and her mother fly to
karachi where her grandma tells the
story of how when she was a kid during
partition she was lost from her family
but the bengal lit the stars and helped
her find her dad so kamala investigates
the train station where oh what's this a
ninja drops in he's another hot teenage
boy named kareem who's a member of the
red daggers a secret society that
protects earth from super threats and
they confirm bruno's calculations
opening the portal to send the gin home
would destroy our world but the jinn
don't care they easily break out of
prison and bad mama leaves comrade here
like hey you betrayed us so i disown you
so now they bust in and that's an
awesome car chase through the street so
wow ramp
but when she stabs the bangle oh it's
train time again but this time not a
vision kamal is transported back in time
we get to see the story of how her jin
great grandmother fell in love with
humans set on the backdrop of india
pakistan partition which by the way was
a massive and terrible event that tore
families apart and americans mostly just
don't know that much about it so they
had a daughter kamala's grandma but her
bad sister caught up to her and they had
to flee and so on the night of the train
kamala's there to help her grandma
reunite with her dad it was her in a
time loop situation now she's blasted
back to the present where the portal has
opened that auntie's like i'm finally
going home but kamala's like yo please
don't destroy the world and so she's
convinced but the only way to close the
portal is for her to sacrifice herself
now kamala reunites with her mom and
grandma who find out she's a superhero
and three generations of moms and
daughters work out all their issues but
when his mother died comrade now gets
her nor powers and the department of
damage control tracks him down he hits
this thing and they accidentally blow up
the convenience store so kamala khan
leaps into action now wearing the
awesome new super suit her mom made for
her the red daggers can get comrant out
of town if they can buy some time so
they go to hideout in the high school
but oh the dodc found them so the whole
group of teenagers come together to make
their final stand now damage control
boss guy is like yo absolutely do not
assault teenagers in a high school but
mean dodc ladies like screw that we're
going in they distract these guys with a
bunch of home alone shenanigans but
their real secret weapon is the
influencer live streaming it which now
makes this a real public event sokamal
is out there protecting comron but when
they pull out the big guns things look
bleak and so kamala comments her classic
comic catchphrase embigin and she uses
her light powers as if they were
stretchy powers whoa hulk smash yeah
that's her but now comron starts to lose
control of his powers kamala's got to go
in there and shield him she gives him
the pep talk that in the end his mom
loved him after all then she breaks a
big hole in the ground for him to escape
through which seems weird but remember
nick fury did it in captain america
winter soldier so i'll allow it so now
jersey city bands together to protect
their hero and mean dodc lady is
obviously very fired so the day is saved
and night light is trending but kamala
really doesn't like that name it's her
papa who gives her a better one when he
reminds her kamala means marvel the name
of her favorite superhero she's not a
captain though so miss marvel is born
ready to fight for what's right in new
jersey but we're not done yet because at
the end bruno's re-looked at what gave
her her powers and he found something
strange in her genetic code it's like a
mutation oh yeah they dropped the m word
x-men coming to the mcu then there's one
more thing in the after credit scene the
bangles acting up and wow in the closet
but it's not her who comes out of the
closet it is carol danvers the captain
marvel it doesn't seem like she
transformed into her it seems like they
swapped places and that's where we'll
pick up in the movie the marvels
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]